three months in the nuthouse was the  longest I've ever been confined so a few  people had been killed it wasn't my  fault please I gotta shut up and lead  you [ __ ]  well maybe it was my fault but I had my  own problems to worry about the old  man's curse was beginning to piss me off  but then one day he showed up Calypso he  called himself it was a stupid name I  wanted to kill him there and then but he  made me an offer he said he ran some  kind of crazy contest if I want his game  he promised to show me how to bring an  end to the curse headaches as much as I  had those old urges of mine I kept them  to myself for the moment I figured I'd  play along with his little game after  all I could always kill him later  you  please days